Growing,
so I think you will see also India,
because it's a young country,
you know,
more than 50 percent of the population
is below the age of uh,
25.
Uh,
so I think you will see a more youthful
culture,
a more exuberant in many ways,
a more matter of fact,
uh,
and this culture is contributing already
and will contribute even more to the
growth of housing.
For example,
young people buying homes.
I think we'll have a lot more cars on
the roads,
a certainly a young population that is
very gripped by technology changes and
very open to everything that the digital
age or offers.
So I think we're going to see an India
in which certainly divides will still be
there.
You will see young urban Indians,
very tech savvy,
very connected to the urban cultures.
You will still have people living in our
villages in very traditional ways as
they do today.
And I think that they will continue at
least for the next 10,
15,
20 years.
And,
uh,
so we,
will be,
I think at a different level,
but as we joke in India about how we
live in all the ages,
the Samsung.